so so for you it's just about you it's
for you
so your background's in what though uh
temple shotokan karate
oh sick and you've been doing that since
a kid uh no i actually didn't start
training in anything until i was 20.
it's not too bad what was your sport
before that nothing
uh truth be told i was never really into
sports or athletic stuff like at all
um before doing martial arts i hate
working out just to work out it's
boring and it drives me nuts you don't
want to be the best what made you say
i want to start fighting like yeah what
made you say but just not any fighting
right right you're rough dude it's
coming from a guy who fought
at a high level dude when i see what you
guys doing like jesus christ man
like there's no there's no medical like
you know like
the the the the refs like [ __ ] it out
let's get it on me is like tattoos
what is happening right yeah it's so
intense
yeah that's so different i'd show them
some videos
you came from a formal sporting
background so i see that
it's like jesus christ like when we you
know kimbo is in the house to be a good
friend of mine
and just watching his videos you're like
oh my god like obviously all of us came
up the traditional way and
organizations you know local shows then
got to the higher level
and but kimbo like everyone had such i
would say even more respect for him
because he came up from the
literally from the [ __ ] backyards and
that now his the way he did was wrong i
mean that was like
real illegal underground fighting where
they were paying them and everything
oh they were just fighting one he's
fighting this one dude and the dude's
pinkie's broken the dude's going like
i'm done i'm done and they're not
stopping
still suck him in the face so kimbo just
kept beating
you're not far off from that man i know
yeah you were fighting a guy and you had
hay all over you
oh yeah dude i actually that that
rematch i actually lost to the hay bales
when i lost the dude yeah like i was
like tripping over the hay bales i'm
like okay well that's a thing like if
you don't know what ground it is you're
doing like those sliding kicks and stuff
you can
you can how's your family feel about you
doing this backyard um
like the first one really like hey mom
are you married girlfriend uh
rachel was cool with it uh she's always
supported my martial arts career in fact
actually she started paying for my jiu
jitsu training back like mma training
back in the day like uh that's like a
long story though like nah now rachel i
could get into the whole
rachel is your girlfriend yeah yeah you
got it yeah sorry
rachel uh she has a kid and so i
i'm a step dad yeah i'm a step dad but i
mean i treat you like she's my own kid
you know yeah
you probably kick ass at it yeah yeah
it's awesome
he was getting we had a question about
one of her tattoos
oh yeah i stopped
i'm an atheist myself so you know it is
what it is you but you obviously
since you don't get paid for kicking
guys in the face you also have a day job
uh not right now do you teach martial
arts
um i was teaching martial arts as part
of a park program volunteering
um i want to my goal is to open my own
school
like my goal right now like short term
is go pro save up some money
open my own school and like teach
full-time for the rest of my life
do you have any experience in wrestling
uh i've seen you try drinking
wrestling judo throws and stuff yeah
i've um
just jiu jitsu all that all that stuff
comes from i've never
i didn't wrestle in high school or
nothing yeah